Please let me get a
divorce.
Although I have dreamed
of strangling the life
out of Victor's body
or having him get hit by a train
or drowning in a bath
of his own brandy vomit,
I think it's kinder to have him
arrested for battery.
Sorry about this, Victor,
but you're going to jail.
Ah!
[grunts]
[crying]
And that's when he hit me.
I'm so sorry
for your pain, ma'am.
Ay, you'll tell us who the black
fella was who did this,
and we'll throw him
in the pokey right quick.
Oh, no,
it--it was my husband.
[cries]
Well, that's another
matter entirely.
Case closed.
I'm telling you,
I was abused by my husband
in a manner that only a divorce
would settle.
Well, let me ask
you something, dear.
Are you a bitch?
What?
Let's go about this
in a different manner.
Were you menstruating
at the time of the incident?
Were you riding
the red river?
And do you have
a raspberry bush?
How dare you?
I was very abused!
Looks to me like
you walked into a door.
[gasps]
Well, that's an outrageous
implication!
And precisely
the sort of assumption
that makes women feel unsafe
to report their abuse
to the police
in the first place!
Well, the rule of thumb
clearly states
that a man can discipline
his wife
with anything no thicker
than his own thumb.
Well, that's the dumbest rule
I've ever heard of!
And that, my dear, is why
your husband hits you.
If you were my wife, I'd smack
some softness into you.
And I'd have hit ya
to be a bit taller.
Perhaps some larger bosoms.
Now that we've settled that,
would you mind running along,
sweetheart,
fetch us a spot of tea?
And perhaps a tour
of the premises.
We hear there's a room
made entirely of candy.
Well, infidelity and abuse
were a bust.
I guess I'm going to have to
kill Victor if I want a divorce.